ان القوات الامريكيه تؤكد بالفعل انها شنت
ضربه في العراق وان هذه ان هذا الهجوم في
بغداد استهدف هدفا فرديا عاليه الجوده او
عاليه القيمه وفق تعبير المسؤول الامريكي
الذي تحدث للجزيره ونرحب ايضا بفادي منصور
من البنتاجون مراسل الجزيره ونريد ان
نسالك فادي عن هذه التصريحات للمسؤول
الامريكي وان كانت هنالك اسماء ام فقط
تعريف لقيمه الهدف الذي استهدفته القوات
الامريكيه نعم وفق مسؤول امريكي تحدثنا
اليه وطلب عدم ذكر اسمه اولا اكد ان
القوات الامريكيه شنت ضربه في العراق
اليوم وبحسب ال قوله فان القوات الامريكيه
ضربت هدفا واحدا في اشاره على ما يبدو الى
الى سياره لكنه لم يحدد عدد الاشخاص
هناك حساسيه للموضوع في تعامل البنتاجون
مع هذه المساله والجانب الامريكي مع هذه
المساله قبل الاعلان عن اي معلومات اضافيه
بحكم التوترات التي قامت في ما بين حكومه
العراق وايضا الولايات المتحده في اعقاب
الضربات الجويه التي شنتها الولايات
المتحده ضد سبعه مواقع مختلفه في سوريا
والعراق الاسبوع الماضي وقول الحكومه
العراقيه انها استهدفت مواقع تابعه للقوات
الامنيه والحشد الشعبي وبالتالي هناك حرص
كما فهمنا من الجانب الامريكي قبل الاعلان
عن هويه الهدف من هو المسؤول او المسؤولون
واي تنظيم يتبعون سواء كتائب حزب الله او
غيره هناك محاوله فعلا لتجميع كل
المعلومات وكل المعطيات ووضعها في طريقه
كامله حتى لا يكون هناك اي التباس او اي
اتهامات للجانب الامريك بانه يستهدف قوات
الحشد الشعبي او القوات الامنيه العراقيه
هل هل نتحدث عن ضربه ام ضربتين لانه من
منذ بدايه هذه الاخبار ونحن نتحدث عن
هجومين وليس هجوما
واحدا ال المعلومه الاخيره التي حصلنا
عليها قبل المشاركه مباشره هي ان هناك
استهداف لهدف واحد في العراق لكن بطبيعه
الحال هناك بعض المعطيات المرتبطه
بالميدان فقط لكي يفهم المشاهد ما الذي
يحصل بعض المعطيات المرتبطه بالميدان قد
لا تكون متوفره بشكل سريع بلدى المسؤولين
هنا في واشنطن سواء في البنتاغون او
مسؤولين اخرين لسبب التالي عندما وافق
الرئيس الامريكي بايدن على توجيه ضربات
ردا على الهجوم الذي وقع على القاعده
الامريكيه في الاردن المعروفه باسم البرج
22 وضعت لائحه اولا بالاهداف
وثانيا بعدد من المسؤولين عن التنظيمات
التي تعتبر الولايات المتحده انها تعمل
كوكيل لايران وهي التي تستهدف القوات
الامريكيه سواء ضمن كتائب حزب الله او
غيرها من التنظيمات ولنتذكر ان الولايات
المتحده تقول بان الهجوم الذي وقع على
القاعده الامريكيه في شمال شرق الاردن
يحمل بصمات كتائب حزب الله وبالتالي هناك
شبه تاكيد بان هذه المجموعه هي المسؤوله
وبالتالي عن عندما وجه الرئيس بايدن
اوامره كان لديه لائحه متكامله بالاهداف
سواء كانت هذه الاهداف عباره عن شخصيات
ومسؤولين قياديين او مواقع عسكريه ومواقع
لتخزين السلاح او مواقع لتخزين الصواريخ
والمسيرات التي تقول الولايات المتحده ان
المجموعات التي تهاجمها تقوم باستخدامها
وهي مجموعات مدعومه من ايران وبالتالي
احيانا عندما تسنح الفرصه لضرب احد هذه
الاهداف الذي اشر عليها الرئيس الامريكي
واعطى الموافقه باستهدافها فان الظروف
الميدانيه هي التي تتحكم بالرد وعاده هذا
التفويض يمنح لوزير الدفاع ومن قبل وزير
الدفاع للمسؤول عن تلك المنطقه وهنا نتحدث
تحديدا عن قائد القياده الوسطى وتحت امرته
عدد من الطائرات الحربيه بطبيعه الحال
والمسيرات والمعطيات الاستخباراتيه وغيرها
من الامور ويتخذ القرار بناء للفرص
السانحه في اطار غطاء سياسي وايضا قرار
تنفيذي من قبل الرئيس بايدن وبالتالي هذه
الضربه تحديدا هناك معطيات متوفره بشانها
لكن حتى هذه اللحظه يفضل المسؤولون سواء
في البنتون او المسؤولين الامريكيين
الاخرين عدم البوح بها حتى اصدار موقف شبه
متكامل على الاقل يمحو اي التباس او اي
ردود فعل تاتي لتقول بان من استهدف هو جزء
من المنظومه الامنيه الرسميه العراقيه او
الحشد الشعبي او غيره من الامور